après plus deux semaines
[Musique]
dites nous trouve le coffre à le dire il
attend quoi dites nous où se trouve le
corps dit nous trouve le coffre ton
flingue ça info ok tu avec une balle
dans son chargeur très bien avec deux
bals d'antan les périodes le lavabo dans
la salle de bain je voulais pas tirer
vous dites nous trouve le coffre quoi
j'ai pas de coffre est de faire sinon ça
va mal finir ok vous jugez pas de corps
ici oui il dit qu'il n'a pas de coop
chez lui pourtant on est bien au 19
comme on va aider ou 19 bis vous êtes au
19 bis
ah oui pardon s'est gouré ah merde le
vase du coup je vous laisse sans mal en
dédommagement je suis désolé attendez je
vous rend la monnaie parce que je les
payais que 94 ou
dites nous trouve le coffre juste pas de
coffre tu vas nous dire où il est encore
j'en ai pas je suis mal organisé j'ai
tout dans la chambre sous matha sous les
gens environ un demi million d'euros
sera ouais mais nous on est venu pour le
corps je vous propose que vous voulez
vous pouvez aller acheter un coffre en
effet dit nous trouve le corps c'est
quoi c'est la clé du coffre
il vient d'avaler la clé du coffre
comment on va faire d'accord c'est un
magicien or et c'est moche j'aimerais
pas le voir dites nous trouve le coffre
j'ai tout l'y faut donc tu serait dispo
vendredi pour voir une pièce de tchekhov
actuellement voire à des bisous tita
c'est bon t'es tout autre le oui l'a dit
nous trouve le coffre
alors bon je pense que je me suis trompé
à s'est dit d'accord
ouais c'est bon fait agresser à et il
n'y a pas de sauce piquante des
d'outreau la sauce décote
[Musique]
eric c'est toi non et si jeudi reconnaît
avec c'est quoi ce une blague est une
fan alors non je confirme c'est pas eric
je suis pas eric mais c'est quoi ce film
et y avait 1 vitesse mais non je suis
pas eric or voilà maintenant j'ai ton
visage c'est le commissariat blanc
montre la photo
ouais mais il croit que je fais rick
s'est pas je m'appelle christian ok
maintenant j'étais que tu t'appelles
christian je vais leur dire aussi t'es
chez moi dit nous trouve le coffre
attendez vous venez de vous voyez vous
donnez cannage je sais pas 34 j'ai 28
ans mais attention je suis toujours
gênant vous crois tu pas cap de faire
des trucs fous on n'a rien dit pourquoi
tu pas capté faire du tout faux celle-ci
ne venons pas braquer la banque combat
aller au dodo un poil trop fort pour moi
le gars en plus il a toujours l'air
vieux quoi c'est juste un jeu avec un
fusil
[Musique]